good evening everyone
pleased to be standing for the prayers
legacy what is left behind when people
move on heart
but sudden and tragic sadness of the
loss of counsel a black my mind was
turned to what is a legacy legacies that
impact and as a result you as counselors
have a huge impact into their life and
well-being of the community that we are
part of in the Bible Jesus talks about
legacy with the grain of mustardseed
with the story of the good vine and with
the story of the grain of wheat where it
grows and flourishes and impacts far
more than anything else you will have
memories of the impact that you have had
in your local community and the people
that you represent and as such that has
a wider impact not only in this chamber
here but in the lives of individual
people that you represent and it is a
powerful thing to be left a legacy and
you as counselors have that joy
privilege honor of leaving an impact
that will change transform challenged
lives across this area in which we live
so make the most of it
and recognize that when you're not here
anymore
that legacy will remain moment of Prayer
father God we come as a gathered
community of representatives of this
community and we ask that your presence
will be felt in this place and across
the borough in all the things that are
decided here in this gathering in this
chamber this evening be with each
individual who stands and speaks and may
they know that they speak with clarity
that will have an impact on lives beyond
this dwelling we bring before you the
family especially of councilor black and
we mourn the loss of his life and the
impact that he had in this council
chamber and with those who lived in his
constituency be especially close to his
wife Eleanor and his son Alex in this
time of loss and grief and God of hope
we come to you in shock and grief and
confusion of heart and ask that you will
draw and send your peace to each and
every one who has been affected by this
sudden loss be with each and every one
here that is represented this day
in the name of Christ amen
and as we remain standing we will have a
minute's silence in memory of councilor
black
thank you
before we go on I would like to say on a
personal front that I was very saddened
at the loss of counselor black he was an
honorable man he worked extremely hard
for this council and for the residents
and he will be a loss to this council so
I just wanted to put that and say that
tonight start the meeting item 1
apologies for ever since have counselor
mrs. Mason counselor John Mason
counselor Rotem counselor mrs. Shaw
counselor Wilson and counselor
Toby Mountain are there any others
item two minutes of the meeting held on
the 18th of July do we agree those item
three to receive declarations of
interest hands going up counselor row
Thank You chairman a non-pecuniary
interest please on item 9 I'm a manager
of one of the contractors and I do hold
a license Thank You counselor Thank You
chairman item knowing a non-pecuniary
interest as a license to pack new
carriage driver counselor web Thank You
chairman I mean item five a
non-pecuniary interesting item four as
I'm a hospital governor thank you Thank
You chairman it's a non-pecuniary
interesting - 9 regard to being a lacist
number 9 on peculiar interests being a
licensed taxi driver thank you
I'm sorry counts to come up item 4 I'm a
governor at Southend University Hospital
Foundation Trust I sit on the West Essex
Clinical Commissioning group on behalf
of Essex County Council I also chair the
local health and well-being board
forecast appointment Rochford I also sit
on behalf of the southern districts of
the county on the essex health and
well-being board as well thank you thank
you
Catman Thank You nan peculiar interest
in item 14 as a member of Rayleigh Town
Council I know that we noted that thank
you
any others thank you right item 4 update
on the mid and South Essex success
regime councillor web madam chairman I
just like to raise a point of order if I
may please before the presentation so I
just like to raise a point of order if I
may before the presentation yes Karen
our council meeting in June watcher
District Council requested that the NHS
and specifically dr. Karen Howard be
invited to attend a future meeting of
council to provide an update on the
success regime prior to the end of the
public consultation period in December
2017 this information was passed on to
the CCG in both July and September
however dr. Howard was not asked to
speak as portfolio holder earlier this
month I specifically requested that dr.
Howard speak at full council tonight and
the CCG were again reminded of the
council request the response that I was
given was that as to why dr. Howard is
not attending is that the most relevant
and senior representative of the
hospitals is dr. Celia Skinner as chief
medical officer for all three hospital
trusts as chief medical officer dr.
Skinner has the complete overview and
the most comprehensive knowledge of the
forthcoming proposals for public
consultation dr. Skinner will be able to
provide the most accurate and up-to-date
information
and she's also very keen to attend in
person to hear the views of your members
I thought that it is a mark of
disrespect to this council that I wishes
to hear dr. Howard speak were not upheld
despite repeated requests to do so why
does this matter
because as council members we want to
hear from all sides of the debates not
just from the management but from the
frontline clinical staff as well from
those that work in an A&E in the stroke
department and in the acute medical
setting when we discuss the only
proposals which were thankfully
subsequently changed as they were shown
to be flawed and clinically unsound
we're only told of the clinical concerns
because doctor held was allowed to speak
and gave us the viewpoint from the south
and based clinician without this
intervention where the plans have been
changed tonight dr. Howard is sitting at
the back of the room unable to
contribute to the debate despite the
best efforts of our counsel madam
chairman in my hand I hold the results
of the bullying and harassment survey
from across South End Basildon and brain
field hospitals it states that between
24 percent and 27 percent of staff
surveyed from bullying suffered from
bullying and harassment in the last 12
months
and I quote it appears that the vast
majority of bullying and harassment is
perpetrated by managers and colleagues
can I suggest that this may extend to
preventing staff speaking as well madam
chairman I would ask therefore that we
suggest disposing the presentation and
can until we can hear from both sides of
the debate as originally requested thank
you dr. Skinner have you got anything to
say to answer that yes please
Thank You manager so counselor Polly
does give her
with responsibility for getting the
three hospitals to work in a different
way in a collaborative way as we try to
respond to the changing needs of the
populations changing healthcare needs
and the changing workforce that we are
all facing and our bottom line here is
that we want to improve the quality of
care and safety in our services and the
sustainability of our services because
of my role I have I'm able to look
across the whole of the changes that
we're trying to make across the
hospitals and also have a greater
insight into the changes the important
changes that our colleagues in primary
care and through the CCGs are trying to
make as well because clearly it's the
whole of the health service coming
together there's going to provide a
better outcome we are not trying to gag
clinicians nurses doctors from speaking
and in all our developments of proposals
we have a process where we share what we
are discussing we involve clinicians at
every stage and then we take it back out
to our clinical teams to say have we got
this right do we need to make changes
what refinement is needed and we
continue to do that process and clearly
we are about to go into we hope a period
of public consultation which will run
for twelve to fourteen weeks which then
not only gives the opportunity for the
public and yourselves to comment on the
proposals but also the staff who are
clearly important stakeholders in this
process well not at that process of
public consultation yet we're trying to
get to a point where we've got what we
think are a reasonable set of proposals
that we can take
thank you for that dr. spinner um I am
concerned that the resolution was passed
at the last meeting to invite dr. Howard
and yourselves to come along and dr.
Howard is not being allowed to speak
however the resolution was to invite and
we have done that and I wouldn't wish to
give you the discourtesy of you've come
along tonight and we would like to hear
your presentation however I would like
to stress that any future invitation to
dr. Howard or any other clinician
wouldn't be blocked we would like to
hear both sides of it but we would like
to hear your presentation tonight if
that's I think perhaps
okay perhaps perhaps maybe this should
be put to the vote of the councillors in
the chamber as to whether they wish to
continue Thank You councillor mine sorry
I didn't see you
that's with watched you haven't big
fellow this is American k-pops that's
fine actually I think it was very same
question know what I was going to say
Wales or suggest two accounts the web
was did he want to make that a form
motion or not
I would very much like to hear count dr.
Howard speak this evening I would be
having to make that as a motion but
madam chairman are so up to you to
decide whether you'd like to invite our
guest to speak first but I would like to
hear from dr. Howard this evening as
well please now we could all hear you
can stay I would like to hear from dr.
Skinner so that we can hear the at least
hear this side of the presentation at
the moment thank you it's not a motion
it's not a motion
it's not a motion
oops an emotion now dr. Skinner
could you give you a presentation please
[Music]
thank you thank you madam chairman I'm
so I'm supported by the Tom Abel who is
the chief transformation officer for the
three hospitals and he's known to you as
the council officer to local CCGs so
just got eight brief slides and then
there's clearly the opportunity for you
to ask questions thank you so as I say
this is and you know this is an update
of where we've got to into this process
and just trying to describe some change
to the hospital services and also to the
services and this is about genuinely
trying to improve the safety of our
services the quality and the
sustainability and sustainably isn't
just about money it's about a
sustainable workforce I'm sure you're
all very familiar from the national
press and your local press and the
difficulties in filling many posts be
there nursing medical allied health
professionals in health care so I'm
gonna update where we are with the three
hospitals you know we're obviously are
talking about Southend it's important
that's in the context of Bazell Dhin and
Mid Essex as well look at these
proposals within the overall context
from where our plan was first published
in October 2016 and say explain to you
how this does fit within a national
framework we're not you know we are
governed as you are we have many people
we have to answer many checkpoints we
have to go through to make sure that the
things that we are suggesting and
consulting on are safe and in the best
interests of our page
and stuff so what we're trying to
describe is a plan a system plan it's
not just about the hospitals it's about
the whole healthcare system so GPS
community providers everybody who
contributes to the health and well-being
of our staff and the briefs basic
promisor that is that we want to support
people to live well some sort of healthy
living agenda we want to invest and
develop local services we know that it's
the right thing to do
but also we have a responsibility to try
and improve the care that we deliver
within the hospitals we know there are
examples of excellence already across
the three hospitals but we know that
they're equal things that we need to do
better
equally recognize that by working
together in collaboration we're more
likely to make those improvements and
what we're describing for this this part
of the country is being replicated
across the other 44 STPs and it's being
replicated internationally all health
systems are having to respond to the big
health changes of aging populations with
complex health needs the opportunities
that technology is beginning to present
to us now deliver health in a different
way and the need to look differently in
terms of how staff provide care towards
patients
so as you are well aware we came with
some proposals which were at proposal
stage earlier in the year around
beginning to think how could we
reconfigure the hospital services
differently and we listened at that
point and we receive from very strong
feedback from many different people that
what we had people were uncomfortable
with so on this on the left hand side of
this slide you can see there was a
strong desire that we maintained 24/7
consult and led emergency departments at
each of the three hospitals that we
should continue with pediatric and
maternity presence at all three sites we
have always said that we have never said
we are going to change that that remains
in the proposals that we wish to get to
consult on that we didn't want the
message we heard and we agree with is
that we want older people and children
where possible should be receiving their
care locally we don't want people
traveling unnecessary around our three
hospitals unless they can only get that
complex care in one particular place
and we also heard very clearly the
uncomfortableness that people articulate
around ambulances by passing their local
hospital
we've listened to that and we've
modified our pros proposals consequently
and as we already recognize both within
the hospital setting and importantly
within the aerelon service we know the
ambulance services don't have the
resource to do a bypass and a big
transfer system we absolutely recognize
that would require investment so what we
have come up with is the development of
a treat and transfer model with local
hospital transport if we do need to move
patients around the system and I can
provide some more detail on that if
that's necessary and in fact dr. Howard
was one of the architects of that change
we want to describe as we always have
that Southend is the cancer service
accounts a sensor for your local
population the local populations of
Bazell Dhin and Mid Essex but to support
that and it augment that we maintain
24/7 consultant-led emergency services
at Southend
there will be at times probably a need
for limited ambulance bypass it already
happens if the paramedics make a
diagnosis of a heart attack
they have conversations and that patient
will go straight to the Cardiac Center
at Basildon where we have nationally
recognized excellent outcomes the same
will happen if a patient needs complex
burns treatment it may well go straight
to the Burn Center
amid Essex this an accepted method of
working as I said again we want frail
elderly ideally to be treated in their
locality in their in it through their GP
practice through their community nursing
team but if they do need to attend the
hospital it should be their own local
hospital the same for pediatrics same
for all for our low for our children can
we treat them locally where that is
possible and as I said as well keep the
obstetric care we've got big obstetric
units keep those where they are but we
want our teams to work together
so 24/7 consultant-led emergency
departments all three hospitals
importantly and I'll show you this in a
graphic supported by assessment units
all three hospitals continue to do blood
tests x-rays outpatients take a surgery
as is now that actually is the bulk of
visits to a hospital it's not patients
being admitted it's people attending for
something all of that continues to be
delivered locally ten Ewing the
maternity services but recognizing and
the research evidence this isn't us
coming up with this as an idea but in
certain complex conditions low volume
complex things it's better to bring
those things together it's better to
create those teams who have specialized
in these areas with the right kit and
probably for our population it's better
to do that once well rather than three
times in a fragment in a fragmented
piecemeal approach
so this may not work and we'll test this
graphic it's not working at the moment
but essentially if you come to hospital
when you come through three routes
through ambulance as a walk-in or
through your GP and what we're trying to
do at the front of each Hospital is
begin to change the way we don't we
don't want people bottlenecks through
the hospital food through the IDI
Department we know that can be a poor
experience for patients and staff we
begin to separate out people a bit so
there will be emergency hub so that's
the emergency department alongside some
GPS alongside some specialists in
medicine surgery older people medicine
pediatrics we could assist the emergency
department in recognizing that there are
people with specific needs and offer the
right treatments and we want all of that
but each of the front doors
metaphorically for the three hospitals
and at that point we may identify a
small number of patients who would
benefit from transfer
if we can treat people in that first
early period or through the ambulatory
care setting where someone perhaps
doesn't need to be in a hospital bed but
needs urgent tests that's what we want
to do we make sure we've got the right
x-ray resource specialist opinion
resource fast blood tests whatever it is
that we can turn around and give
somebody an early diagnosis and not have
to admit them to a bed for a series of
things to happen and we're trying to
enhance that across all three sites if
people do need to be admitted the vast
majority of patients will be admitted
locally as they are now there will be a
minority where we say actually you think
it's better we consolidated some of this
experience in a different setting and
you're gonna get a better outcome a
small part of your care like
we don't own this process the cute
hospitals it's in colleagues across the
five CCGs who own this process and
they're working together in a joint
committee to help us get to the point of
public consultation
public consultation hopefully ads
proposals that we put forward makes them
stronger makes them better makes them
sit with what is will improve health
outcomes but it's the CCGs then to say
okay we get with this let's try and
implement those changes and those
changes will take years to implement
this isn't something that's going to be
happening in April 18 decisions will
only be made in 2018 and we have bid
nationally for investments limited
investment to try and make these changes
possible we've yet to hear the outcome
and anything we do will obviously have
to have fully worked up plans sensible
logical ways in which to implement and
at the heart of that test that tests
that with the doctors and the nurses to
think this is going to improve
so we're in a series of dates meetings
which and all this time scale is set
externally this is set through NHS
England isn't our behest and it's
certainly true that over the summer
we've had to accelerate things that was
outside of our control but work within a
wider framework so we're now at the
point trying to go back to the
investment committee can we get some
additional investments to the system and
that will hopefully provide the green
light it's a public consultation in
November and it'll be a long period of
not of consultation we reflecting that
that probably will run over the
Christmas period so it would be extended
to facilitate
tom is there anything you want
no I think the only thing about I would
want to add to the process is clearly
we're not at have we're not in a
position yet where we have a firm set of
definitive proposals around exactly how
each of the clinical services would
operate and that is something that we
will have in the coming upcoming weeks
once we've gone through this assurance
process and the work that the clinical
Senate and that we were more than happy
to bring those more detailed proposals
back and indeed we're more than happy to
bring the clinical leads from across our
three hospitals to talk to you about
what they mean and so so looking at how
what the evidence base is around
bringing together certain low volume
specialties as seniors described so
we're not in that place at the moment
and we will be in that place hopefully
next month once we get through the
assurance process and so this is really
just an update in terms of where at in
that kind of process that we're having
to go through with colleagues and the
change that we've made from in the
conversation that we had when we last
met with you when we last met with
others around taking any kind of major
change to the three accident and
emergency departments over three
hospitals of the time
so no decisions have been made yet I
think that's the most important thing
the consultation will be exactly that's
a consultation and we anticipate that
our clinical model and the details of
how that work will need to change and
refine as we listen to local communities
and indeed we listen to the entire
clinical body from across the three
hospitals we employ somewhere in the
region of about 17,000 staff across for
three hospitals so it has not been
possible to engage everybody in that
process yet and we want to be able to do
that over the course of this 14 week
period so I anticipate things will
change we are more than happy to come
back once we've got the more detail
around exactly how to clean the clinical
model of work we're more than happy to
bring our technicians who have led and
thought through the individual service
changes at an individual specialty level
very very conscious that we wanted to
give you an update following the last
meeting particularly around this issue
on a na
ambulance bypassed that we know was of
such significant concern to you and so
we could tell you face-to-face that
actually we were taking those proposals
off the table following the feedback
that you provided us however there's
still more work to be done there's still
more engagement to be done and we are a
long long way away before making a final
decision which you know as on that slide
it would not be until March 2018 so
there's still a lot more time to engage
discuss debate refine and that's what we
are committed to doing and I hope
actually given the decision around alien
ambulance services has shown that
actually we are willing to listen and we
are willing to change where there are
major concerns about any of the
proposals
thank you so just just from a CCG
perspective just to say that we have to
work as a system we know that we've got
hospital care and that demand continues
to be the case for change and that is
never easy but there's a sister we've
recognized that we need to make changes
you can't do this alone and caelius
alluded to the a sponsible care and
there was just as much important that we
get the hospital care the provision that
actually we can do more and you
mentioned this last time we met with you
within our localities to actually
recreate or create an environment that
is safer more appropriate and easier for
patients to access we have to look that
about in its totality we have to engage
ensure engagement is happening between
and commissions that is happening only
males wave is the CCG we we had a really
good meeting with some of the key
consultants from South in hospital Najib
ears to discuss some of this
recognizing that it's not formed yet
there's still a little way to go and
that things will change but I hope that
you will see that from the feet that
we've already received as Tom solutely -
you know we are this thing they're
trying to hear what it is you're you're
saying what your concerns are and
looking to see how we address them and
we will continue to do that as we
progressed on this time
thank you
councilor web
but the proposals remain as noted
earlier what we asked for was a debate
but I thought we've been given a very
good sales pitch I would very much like
to hear from the clinicians who work in
these specialties and to take you up on
that offer of clinicians coming here and
actually speaking to us please the
particular I'd like to ask our staff
have been consulted I'm concerned how
much consultants for both Southland
buzzard and Broomfield who may be
opposed to these changes but I may be
been pushed into agreeing with the
viewpoint that's been put forward and
perhaps the culture is emerging where
senior clinicians are not able to air
their own views as has been evidenced
this evening through dr. Howard not
being permitted to speak the talk is of
planning to recruit transfer team to
manage the transfer of patients but I'd
ask how are you actually going to
recruit transfer teams which will need
Andy statists nurses paramedics when
you're when you're already struggling to
recruit any staff and have gaps in other
roles what if there are four emergencies
at once on-site and staff all out on
transfers and have been enough stranded
another hospital or if someone is
transferred and they're not considered
necessary for speciality admission and a
Jew transported home which transferred
back to the hospital
this relates multiple journeys and
inconvenience even even more so if
they're elderly or infirm my key concern
is based on a central theme of the
clinical evidence around transferring
patients and the evidence for some of
the proposals that are coming forward my
concern is that this will not lead to a
base that I don't come for the patients
that then they gets now alright I remain
concerned that at heart this is a cost
saving exercise that does not have
increased patient outcomes at its heart
madam chairman with these concerns in
mind I would like to put forward a
motion to the council has concerns about
the impacts that these proposals will
have on our local residents and how they
would improve patient outcomes and we
remain concerned about the level of
clinical input until we've been able to
have a balanced debate and heard from
frontline staff being allowed to speak
freely I didn't thought Mable to support
these proposed changes thank you
councillor gooding thank you madam chair
I'd like to second the motion put
forward by councillor web and retain the
right to speak at the end of debate does
that mean the presentation is no longer
taking place there are no questions now
allowed so we we have a motion on the
floor so we need to be speaking to the
motion so I have I have you councillor
hi down as the next week anyway I'm not
speaking to motion over not speak to it
I came for something else I think the
motion and Shippingport is the one that
Thank You councillor Ward thank you
madam chairman thank you
I just a wee bit confused and it just
like some clarification if I may madam
chairman from from those who have given
this presentation I believe that the
three clinical leads who would be Diane
soccer sue this Skinner who is here this
evening
we are actually cancelling well we are
speaking to the motion
thank you does anybody else want to
speak to this much counts to step to
anyone want to speak to the motion could
I just speak to the motion please after
all without ask being able to ask
questions of the people who made the
presentation tonight I don't feel well
enough in formed from the information I
have gone at myself although that is
quite substantial to be able to judge
properly whether the motive of our
consequent emotion or not perhaps
counsel Webb might like to answer the
questions instead
it was my understanding but the
questions could be taken to the motion
as well
German questions to the motion yes no
questions and questions to the panel as
well no I'm sorry once the motion has
been put and seconded then we can only
talk to the motion and counselors can
only talk so we've got anybody else want
to speak on that so do we want to vote
on the motion perhaps you could make it
a bit repeat what it is again please yes
thank you madam chairman
the motion that the council has concerns
about the impact these proposals will
have on our local residents and how they
will improve patient outcomes and remain
concerned about the level of clinical
input I feel until we've been able to
have a balanced debate and heard from
frontline staff being allowed to speak
freely I do not feel able to support
these proposed changes and councillor
gooding did you want to sum up just asad
to have these same concerns and I'm
really concerned that there isn't the
clinical evidence that backs up what our
residents would wish and that is
outcomes for them regarding these
changes with the transfer tree and
transfer situation
thank you anybody else want to speak to
this no so can we put it to the vote
then those in favor of the motion that
is carried thank you thank you dr.
Skinner and stable and the states did
Stern thank you for your time
item 5 which is announcements from the
chairman leader ahead of paid service
there's just a couple of things I would
like to say this is Rob Manning's last
meeting as our one five one officer and
I would like to say thank you very much
for your input over the last however
long here nearly two years and welcome
to Miami Lucas who's taking over as the
one five one officer I won't run through
all the things I've been doing over the
last few months but I have represented
this council on numerous occasions both
in the district in Essex and as far as
in some parts of London there's been
some very interesting things that I've
done one in particular wasn't very grand
but I have visited a local resident who
has been doing good deeds in our in our
district for about the last 50 years
without any recognition and it was
really nice to meet her and that they're
the sort of people that I'm really
enjoying meeting but I also helped give
an award to the first company in our
district to win the business standard
award which was which was very good for
our businesses in in Rockford too so say
I won't go through everything else but
rest assured I've been exceedingly busy
and attending events weekends and during
the week so that's just just for me so I
don't know leader I had a paid service
no no right item six public questions
are members questions or notice there
are none item 7 business from the last
council meeting there is none item 8 to
note the minutes of executive and
committee meetings held between the
period of the 15th of July to the 8th
6th of October and they're listed
counselor hi chairman in noting those
minutes I just like it noted that on the
6th of September of night and four of
those notice of executive decisions
there was decision the car parking
charges and all council car parks be
suspended on the SAS cities during
December 17 prior to Christmas the dates
are the second the ninth 16 to the 23rd
23rd of December tonight 2017 because we
have a motion I think coming up later
chairman that says exactly that same
thing
thank you thank you did you want to
thank you Jeff madam chairman and thank
you guys Scott what getting it back no
speculation the right one which raised
was on item 6 the executive of the 6th
of September I have spoken to mr.
Manning about this already it's
concerning the quarter one financial
report and there was a common are made
aware the m22 took mr. Manning where the
catch now it runs on RIT migration
project the budget and was not stated
correctly as I understand I think you've
got a firm that or not thank you
as rightly pointed out to us though in
one of the capital tables we incorrectly
reported the IT migration project budget
unfortunate that was updated on the 23rd
of May but we didn't actually pick it up
in the q1 report so that what that
should say is the latest budget is
around six hundred and forty two
thousand pounds and our outer and spend
against that as we are cut away as we
were in q1 was around five hundred and
ninety eight thousand which would give
us a forty four thousand under spent so
there's a correction thank you so can we
so we're now going to item nine to
consider reports from the executive and
committees to Council so first one is
counselor mrs. Weston please thank you
madam chairman
yes we had a meeting on the appeals
committee last week two amendments to
the hackney carriage private hire driver
or fraser license conditions and it's
just proposed that ask the council to
resolve 1.4 I may please madam chairman
is that agreed Thank You councillor
Burton please Thank You venture as dito
the review committee undertook an annual
review of the council's Ripper policy on
the 3rd of October whilst there are
several changes that proposed these are
relatively minor and mainly relate to
amendments to watch a District Council
staff referred to in the councils policy
and also two changes following the
abolition of the existing regulatory
bodies and the creation of the IP CEO
who are now responsible for the judicial
over view sites have covered
surveillance by public authorities
throughout the UK is therefore the
Review Committee's recommendation that
council accepts the updated Ripa policy
as per the officers report with the
inclusion of an additional statement
referring to the use of young or
vulnerable people if any members have
any questions I'm sure that the reason
most would be happy to answer thank you
very much is that great members
sorry chairman if I may just just sorry
in response I've just spotted this on
nine point three it's been a great turn
off and I need the officer's name
Patricia Patricia Christie is no longer
an officer of this council so therefore
it be taken off that list on page nine
point three eight is that noted item
nine one counts the top-maul place Thank
You chairman I'm just to nominate cancer
on you as the portfolio holder
Enterprise on to the harbor all
authority representing this council
thank you is that great item ten report
on urgent decisions there are none item
11 report of the leader of the work of
the executive councilor couple Thank You
chairman right this is the second
ordinary full council meeting of the
1718 municipal year and I would like to
welcome all members since the meeting on
the 18th of July the executive has met
on three occasions during which
considerations that included the
financial out turn 2016-17 management
report and the quarter one in 1718
financial management a performance
report also recommendations from the
Investment Board on its review of asset
register sites and the wyvern phase one
project other matters that my colleagues
and I on the executive dealt with
include the approving of the
environmental health service plan for
2017-18
amending the heads of terms of the
public realm agreement to incorporate
the essex county councillors hire a
range of service and the recommendations
to the member reviser group on
allocations of the second round of
funding to local voluntary organisations
and finally of submitting a form
response to the London borough of havens
regulation 19 publication draft local
plan consultation through you madam
chairman as always I would be happy to
take any questions from members in
respect of the work of the executive and
I'm sure my executive colleagues will be
happy to contribute where appropriate
thank you ma'am Thank You councillor
come around any questions right so now
it's item 12 which is the motion on
notice councillor hi thank you very much
madam chairman obviously a casa cameras
pointed out this motion intercessions
been agreed already the motion was
brought forward by members of the group
in July this year and basically on the
basis that the administration has acted
on it already through the meeting of the
executive in September's - pointed out
last council cut more I can confirm that
a significant emotional winning to some
talking very quickly I think are willing
to withdraw it and would like to thank
the executive for listening to us and
acting so confident to our concerns now
we lost just like confirmation if
possible from the section one for every
one officer that this has been costed
and is affordable Thank You chairman
it's one get this working
I don't think members of the executive
we're aware this motion was coming
forward before the executive it is
something we've done every year since I
can remember I think there must be at
least 10 12 years now so whilst I
accepted the motion that was put forward
and the spirit in which it was given I
think it's a bit sort of superfluous
really in as much as it was something
that was going to be considered in any
event pending the fact that obviously
the finance is permitted which we
clearly thought there could be so you
know I think we're all the point is
we're in violent agreement I think about
this this motion has it as it stood and
so I'm brie the police that all sides of
the house as far as I can tell are
actually in support of this Thank You
chairman
at the executive meeting on the 26th of
July the American director did inform
the executive that there was a motion
put forward in July yeah yeah I just
confirmed that as reported at quarter
one the councilors reporting on the
spent of 91 thousand pounds projected
for the end of the year so there is
sufficient resources within the NPS to
to fund that sand thank you and as
everyone said because this has already
been agreed it's not appropriate to
debate this yeah that's right so thank
you and least everybody from all sides
is in agreement that our residents can
have free parking in for Saturday's
running up to Christmas which is good
for them so item 13 mr. Scranton Thank
You chairman
the future of Essex interesting an
interesting topic perhaps much work has
been carried out over a great number of
months to produce a document the future
of Essex I have a copy here and there is
a black and white version of it appended
to your agenda now the purpose of the
future of Essex is to give all the many
different communities groups and
businesses of Essex a way to collaborate
in planning our future key messages are
to set out the kind of Essex we want to
live in to transcend short term agendas
and move us towards the big things that
matter to all of us when take pride in
our County now the vision recognizes
that because change is always coming we
want to make sure it's positive and that
it happens on our terms the vision sets
out seven long term ambitions and those
are summarized in paragraph 3.4 of the
report
a key message the practical
recommendation in the report going
forward for the next period of time next
six months or so are set out in
paragraph four point three partners
being asked to promote the vision and
engage with stakeholders identify and
build on existing pieces of work that
exemplify the vision begin new work to
support the vision where appropriate
build system coherence by creating a
golden thread that links the vision to
other strategies and to widen the system
of leadership and invest in staff and
organizational development now the
ambitions that are set out in the future
of Essex I think in large measure I
would suspect members would not disagree
with and actually they do parallel some
of the ambitions that are in the
council's on business plan and are
recently adopted people plan I think
some members had a session a training
session on the people plan very very
recently so chairman the the
recommendation is is to is the council
results to endorse the vision and the
ambition set out in the future of of
Essex document thank you
Thank You chairman I won't speak at
length on this because I don't think
there's anything in this that any member
would object to I'd like to think
clearly I think we do need a vision for
Essex in as much as we are an entity we
are a collection of eclectic people I
think in Essex that there are very
different people in Essex from one into
the other from north of the south and I
think largely this document sort of
represents that as well but we do need
to make clear about what we're wanting
4:06 about how we want a future for
Essex and how we want to get the
investment the growth that we need to
make sure Essex is an even better place
than it is already
to live in it does have a unique
character chairman other than that
popularized I think on the television
that I think some people can identify
with but many others can't and I think
Essex is a great place to live to bring
up your children to work and to play and
I think some of this document certainly
represents that chairman and I look
forward to endorsing it Thank You
councillor mr. high thank you madam
chairman I - I think he said an
interesting document I don't think many
people would disagree with the things
went to do all the following - made I
think some of it is a bit ambiguous some
of it may be slightly contradict
contradictory status though it's we
don't they're ignoring their provision
of the of the commute where it's talked
about making better transport and links
to London as far as offered well here
but um it might be transporting us with
unity exotic I think there's work to do
on it snow which I understand is the
point of this I just do have a certain
would would looking at this it could
have impacts upon our business came to
some extent of how we could we work in
would would we be looking to review our
views defending line with this as well
thank you
Chairman I think it's a it's appropriate
that we continue regularly to look at at
the business plan so I mean I think the
point is is a male a well-made one and
what I would consider is that we'll look
at the seven ambitions that are included
within the the future of Essex and seek
to show in reports and so on how we
actually are reflecting those in the
work that we're doing I mean the main
principles though of our business plan I
think are clearly are clearly set so it
would be more around the margins that we
would we would look at opportunities to
ensure that we're showing how we are
going forward with the with the document
any further questions so the
recommendation is that the council
resolves to endorse the vision and
ambition set out in the future of Essex
document he says that grade item 14
public spaces protection order mr.
Hutton
we talk loud enough to travel
a buena ok oh the report sets out to
introduce public space protection orders
under the anti-social behaviour crime
and police act 2014 these and the main
SIG's replace the existing 2008 dog
control orders those be rescinded this
November and they also seek to address
specific issues they've been identified
through presentation and sufficient
evidence of antisocial behavior matters
members may recall though drafted a
public space protection orders were
circulated in the memorable have seen in
late August
these have been revised to reflect the
orders at present time our view to
present sufficient evidence to satisfy
the required conditions for their
introduction so basically say that we've
removed certain orders that we feel that
this at this stage we have not enough
evidence to sort of satisfy the
evidential requirements of the act and
therefore you have a pared down set of
these at this stage but I'm happy to
take any questions on this matter
on page 14 the first counsel requested
that obviously I think if you do leave
them parish council employees as
officers give some rights to the power
in the banquet they enforce it also
gives because so the power that their
training and with a lot they're equipped
together with enforce these laws so it's
just
I mean certainly I think at a later
stage we study intend to talk to the
parachutes about how they wish to see
this implemented there may be advantages
to having officers delegated and I need
to see how it works legal transitive to
some advice on that but it is possible
but equally I'd be cautious that perhaps
having Parrish sort of officers given
these powers bless not so you won't
consider it there's pretty where we
considered at some time so thank you
madam chairman yes just a question to
Marcus in Santa but the some of the old
orders that will no longer continue
because of having to meet the new
criteria that sort of evidence of
previous history I'm presume that still
being held on record just in case any
further problems arise in those areas
may how add to possibly the
implementation of anything in the future
records antisocial behavior complaints
that are kept on record regardless so
you know this is not the beer one end of
all the public space always we may
present there may be ones in the future
as well but it does require the
evidential base to be able to do so
you
germán I've just been looking at that
the report and and the report says in
quite mundane and polite language what
really actually has become a pretty
desperate problem not just for Rochford
but for many local authorities around
the East of England we we simply can't
can not recruit experienced qualified
planning offices and it's a real problem
an issue I think for that the planning
service in Rochford hence the reason for
bringing this report to you this evening
it's a straightforward amendment to the
the pay policy to allow the council some
flexibility in the remuneration for
planning officers that hopefully will
give us an opportunity to compete better
in the marketplace chairman thank you
you